Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Spesso sentiamo dire che l'Italia, per crescere, ha bisogno di innovazione.
Cerchiamo allora di capire, in pochi minuti, cosa vuol dire innovare
e quali sono i componenti necessari affinché ciò avvenga.
Prima di tutto bisogna chiarire il concetto di innovazione:
spesso si confonde invenzione con innovazione,
ma sono due aspetti correlati ma non proprio uguali.
Per innovare non è sempre necessario inventare qualcosa di nuovo -
come ad esempio le grandi invenzioni che ci sono state,
pensiamo a Edison per la lampadina, o Marconi per la radio -
ma inventare vuole anche dire reinventare qualche cosa di esistente.
Se pensiamo ad esempio a Starbucks, Starbucks ha preso un prodotto esistente,
largamente utilizzato (il caffè)
e ha reinventato tutto quello che c'era intorno a questo prodotto.
E di fatto ne ha creato uno nuovo.
Quindi, altre innovazioni che ci sono state in Italia,
soprattutto nel campo informatico, possiamo vedere questi due esempi
che sono YOOX e vcast- sono due siti che hanno provato a prendere
dei prodotti esistenti e a reinventarli attraverso Internet.
Il primo ha cercato di portare la user experience dello shopping,
dell'acquisto di abiti, on-line e il secondo ha provato a virtualizzare
videoregistratori quindi a rendere questo dispositivo disponibile
attraverso una semplice interfaccia Web.
Un altro esempio di innovazione - posso portare il mio piccolo caso, che è appunto Skebby.
Io, di fatto, non ho inventato niente ma ho fatto una piccola innovazione
perché ho preso gli SMS, un prodotto esistente,
ho realizzato un'applicazione per cellulari,
e ho permesso di inviare SMS dal cellulare attraverso la rete Internet
invece della rete normale degli operatori.
Quindi anche questo è un esempio di innovazione.
L'innovazione, però, non è sufficiente, l'idea è solo una parte dell'innovazione,
l'idea bisogna anche realizzarla e portarla sul mercato
e bisogna dimostrare che effettivamente funzioni. Per fare tutto questo,
sono necessarie una serie di componenti, che vediamo qui brevemente.
Prima di tutto ci sono le scuole: la scuola, l'Università deve formare,
deve formare i ragazzi e far capire che se uno ha un'idea
effettivamente può essere un imprenditore, può prendere la sua idea
e realizzare un progetto, un'azienda, e se è abbastanza coraggioso
può anche portarla a livello internazionale.
Dopodiché ci sono i finanziatori, ovviamente:
sono molto importanti nell'innovazione, perché ovviamente i primi anni
un'azienda tipicamente perde soldi e sono necessari soldi per finanziare,
per provare prototipi, per provare nuovi modelli di business.
Dopodiché abbiamo i media:i media tipicamente hanno un potere enorme,
e ahimè in Italia sono più - dovrebbero cercare di portare all'attenzione
dei modelli, magari, per i giovani, non solo tipo il Grande Fratello,
magari raccontare qualche storia di successo di imprenditori innovativi
che hanno fatto qualche cosa di interessante.
Dopodiché abbiamo gli investitori istituzionali che servono, diciamo,
durante questo processo di innovazione.
E infine abbiamo il Governo che dovrebbe supportare l'innovazione,
dovrebbero fare delle leggi che aiutino i giovani a intraprendere questa strada,
e non limitarle: ad esempio, in Italia abbiamo delle leggi sulla privacy
estremamente complesse, estremamente corpose,
magari quelle più complesse d'Europa, e forse nel mondo.
Ma queste leggi bloccano: se pensiamo a Facebook o a Twitter,
questi due servizi non potevano nascere effettivamente in Italia.
Allora, tutti questi componenti sono, in vari paesi del mondo,
sviluppati, più o meno: per quanto riguarda l'informatica,
il posto dove questo ecosistema è più sviluppato è sicuramente la Silicon Valley.
L'Italia, ahimè, non siamo sicuramente alla loro altezza, ma qualcosa c'è.
Io posso raccontare la mia esperienza, io ero all'Università,
durante l'Università, un corso universitario ho avuto questa idea
di creare questa applicazione.
Successivamente il mio corso prevedeva di realizzare un business plan,
quindi ho avuto l'opportunità di scrivere questo piano,
e successivamente ho realizzato il mio prototipo, ho portato
l'idea in un prototipo, e i media mi hanno, diciamo, scovato, per fortuna
e hanno fatto da fatto da copertura mediatica a livello nazionale.
Questo mi ha permesso di emergere, diciamo, dall'anonimato,
e ho attirato l'attenzione di alcuni investitori e sono riuscito a coinvolgere
due business angels nel mio progetto.
E stiamo portando avanti con loro questo progetto, e siamo riusciti anche a ottenere
dei bandi pubblici per continuare a svilupparlo.
Tutto questo, quindi, ha portato a questi risultati: in quattro anni
siamo riusciti ad avere oltre un milione di utenti, di cui oltre il 30% all'estero,
oltre a 4500 aziende e, da non dimenticare, diamo lavoro a dieci persone.
Quindi in Italia è possibile innovare?
Sì, sicuramente è più difficile rispetto ad altri paesi,
ma è importante far capire che si può fare anche qui.
Grazie.
(Applausi)